change to change to change change change
change change change here's what I've
created for my life and anyone I know
succeeded I'm a 17 year old kid from
Azusa California with no real education
other than self education with no
background with parents that did their
best all of them
with no money but I did one thing I love
people and I had an enormous demand I
made it by myself and I sculpted my mind
and my emotions to get me to do whatever
it would take to achieve and to
contribute but to do that I did it by
using my body and changing my focus I
did it by putting myself in a peak
physiology and using what I call
incantations can you train yourself to
believe something yes or no absolutely
how many have ever made the fatal
mistake of going to Disneyland or Disney
World and while you're there made the
fatal mistake of going to a ride called
it's a small world after all what
happens for about a week after you're
out of that damn place you're still
singing this thing in your hand in 24
languages right well let me tell you
something how many of you have things
when you want to achieve them and this
part of your voice goes oh it's not
gonna happen or forget it I'm gonna go
to voice that sometimes interrupts that
good pattern say ah and what you want to
do is train a new one so starting when I
was 17 I started doing incantations not
affirmations affirmation you don't
unhappy unhappy amantha I'm happy I'm
happy
what's the problem you haven't changed
your what your what physiology if you
don't change your physiology you won't
get anything so an incantation only you
speak it but you embody what you're
saying with all the intensity you can
and you do it with enough repetitions
that it sticks in your head like it's a
small world now the conversation your
head is always the same and it gives you
what you want
so use your body and your voice so 17
years ago I started doing things I was
working for Jim Rohn this speaker and I
was 17 years old
I had long hair minestrone soup acne on
my face I was trying to call on Bear
Stearns type of people and convince them
why they
go to this man seminar be more
successful I was driving a 1968
Volkswagen I'd earned it $40 a week as a
janitor the only way I did it was parked
far from the building and then go in and
I love people I believe what I put
myself in state and I was able to
influence people that were far more
successful I was at the time I will do
something that I still do backstage and
have done for 23 years because I don't
hope I'm gonna be in a good State I
demand it so I do an incantation using
my whole body that's and now command my
subconscious mind to direct me in
helping as many people as possible live
today to better their lives they gave me
the strength the emotion the persuasion
the humors abruptly whatever it takes
you surely feel and get these people to
change your lives now I will do that
literally driving in my Volkswagen to a
meeting in LA on the freeway for 40
minutes people to look i'm screaming
about my lungs they're going i know he's
a serial killer I know he is but by the
time I entered that room when two people
meet if there's a rapport the person
who's most certain will always influence
the other person and I was probably
certain and they were trying to get
revved up to certainty do you agree with
this yes or no I do another one because
I was poor I changed my mindset I kept
doing things but I never got beyond it
I'd say gods wealth is circulating in my
life as well flows to me and avalanches
of abundance all my needs desires and
goals are met instantaneously by
infinite intelligence I'm one with God
and God is everything and I would
imagine the abundance in my life and I
would feel so grateful and I went for
making 38 thousand dollars a year to
make a million dollars a year and one
year now if you're looking to instigate
a change in your life there's no better
or worse time than right now hey I
understand change is scary with the
status quo you know what you've got and
you shake things up there's no telling
what you might end up with but two of
the things are true about change one is
absolutely necessary for first of all
and two is gonna happen
either you could pick the time to
instigate the change the one or the
change and the time will pick you so if
you happen to be one of those people
who's standing on the sidelines of your
dreams waiting for that perfect moment
if you want to make that change but you
just don't know if you're ready this
life lesson is for you it's time to stop
digging your potatoes and jump I think
everything has to be a closed loop you
drive it with people you measure it with
the people and then you go visit it and
you go visit the progress now you'll get
a lot of air and nonsense when you go
visit you'll see it'll be it mean for
example in Six Sigma if the amount of
savings I was presented in the course of
Six Sigma we're all added up it would
have been larger than the GDP of the
United States so I mean the the
PowerPoint slides can accumulate
enormous events so all these things
hypeeeee to an extent but they gotta be
you cannot you cannot make change with
rational behavior you cannot make change
but like let's have quality programs
quality is good everybody let's go at it
let's make sure our customers feel good
with that with our quality do you guys
say no quark I call these things we've
got to improve it dramatically only the
best people can be on it
half of our offices by the Year 2005
will it will have been black belts in
quality the stock options and the awards
are going to those leading the efforts
and you've got to be you've got to be a
maniac about it to move it you gotta be
over here with the needle to get the
needle here as a businessman how did the
loss of Chris affect you well I mean he
was someone that would take all of our
initial meetings for new opportunities
and then kind of sorted out before this
even brought to my attention so it's
definitely a huge adjustment to me but
I'm not afraid to change so you know it
was
I wasn't prepared for it you know is it
definitely awkward and uncomfortable you
know that to go to that but I'll make
the adjustments you know I whatever it
is like in my life I've had to do that
like this always a constant there'll be
a change there'll be something else to
just goes wow this is not gonna be like
this tomorrow I'm completely different
and how do you figure it out
I think like the record company itself
music business is shifting so
dramatically that you go.that figure out
how to do it and it's not gonna be our
outline for you to actually do it the
right way somebody's gonna have to work
and find a new way so I feel like I'm
the guy all the time when I go into
these businesses to rehabilitate them or
help them grow or get them back on the
right track one of the things that I
notice more often than not is that they
have a pride of authorship that is so
riddled with ego that anybody else's
ideas no matter how good they are just
aren't good enough and look change is
hard it's hard for everybody and so if
anybody tells you it's not hard they're
not telling you the truth
but I'm looking for a business owner to
be willing to consider open to listening
willing to try things and can accept the
fact that every idea they have isn't a
great one and that there may be a good
idea out there a better way to do things
are usually the ones that can excel the
fastest they're the ones that are
willing to accept the change there are
the ones that make the greatest business
partner no I'm not looking for people to
agree to everything and sometimes I say
things that are ridiculous just to see
if they push back because there's a very
fine line between them having passion
and pushing back and basically being a
hard head and saying no to everything
when you change
the way you look at things the things
you look at change Albert Einstein once
observed that you have the most
fundamental and major decision that you
have to make in your life is this do I
live in a friendly or a hostile universe
which is it is it a universe that is
filled with hostility and anger and
people wanting to hate each other and
people wanting to kill each other is
that what you see because when you see
the world that way that's exactly what
you will create for yourself in your
life
this is from great scientific minds and
the interesting thing is that this is
not just a a clever play on words that
when you change the way you look at
things the things you look at change
it's actually a very scientific thing
and I'm going to show you that in just a
moment I'd like you to imagine the
following scene you're in your house
you've got your car keys in your hand
the lights go out
power failure you can't see a thing you
stumble around in your living room and
you drop your keys and you look around
for a moment and you realize that you're
never going to find them in the dark but
you look outside and you notice that the
street lights are on so in your mind a
light bulb goes off hmm I'm not gonna
sit around here in the dark and grope
around looking for my keys when there's
a light on outside I'm gonna go out here
under the streetlight I'm gonna look for
my keys
why are you laughing this is this makes
a lot of sense so you're out here and
you're groping around and you're looking
for your keys and you're looking and
looking and your neighbor comes along
and says what happened wait well I
dropped my keys oh I'll help you look
for him and the two of us are now down
here looking for our keys and looking
finally he says to me excuse me but
where did you drop your keys well I
dropped him in the house he said you
mean to tell me that you dropped your
keys in the house and you're looking for
them out here and the streetlight
doesn't make any sense and I said well
doesn't make any sense to grope around
in the dark when there's light out here
now you laugh and you think how silly
that is but isn't that exactly what we
do when we have a problem a difficulty a
struggle that is located inside and
we're looking for the solution outside
some place outside of ourselves it would
be like going to the doctor and telling
him all of your symptoms and the doctor
says huh boy you've got a lot of
symptoms and he starts writing out
prescriptions you need a prescription
for this symptom you need a prescription
for that symptom and finally he gets
this four or five and you go to walk out
and you say well I'd like my
prescriptions he said no no I'll give
this one to your mother-in-law and I'll
give this one to your neighbor and I'll
give this one to your daughter and I'll
give this one to your father I mean
you're the one with the struggles and
with the difficulties and giving
expecting somebody else to change or
something outside of you to get better
in order for you to make your life work
at this level that I'm calling intention
is something you have to really take a
hard look at it's in here you know
recently I reorganized a bit to focus on
product areas and I think you know in
any company as it grows you know if the
company's not static which shouldn't be
you know has it grows and it changes you
know you need to reorganize it and just
questions you know are you keeping ahead
of that and looking at the our business
was pretty complicated we have all these
different products we have advertising
we have search we have chrome we have
and
we have YouTube and so on and those
things are actually relatively different
they have different different things
going on so I think you know I kind of
moved that up a level in the company and
made sure that we were super focused in
each of those areas
on what our user experience was and I
think that's that's helped just
generally as you switch to a company as
we got more offices you know as we got
time zone differences we had to change
how we did our meetings change how we do
our employee communications and so on so
I just think you know anti-technology
business is growing rapidly I just need
to make sure you're changing everything
you know you're being responsive to that
change and changing everything you know
every year or else you're just not
keeping up with it discipline I had to
get into was I always pay myself first
even when I had no money and would have
all these bill collectors calling me I
use them as inspiration really Oh wonder
how the government's hounding you bill
collectors calling because I've been
broke so I can you understand what it
feels like to be Pro when those guys are
calling you instead of you know
shrinking and going into the shell and
eating my pizza I use it as motivation
to go out and make more money so I used
that I used my bill collectors as
motivation and that's why I paid myself
first even though sometimes I would you
pay yourself I was bought assets I'd buy
a house or I'd put money in the bank and
things like this but it was just a habit
look what exact was you're talking about
it's up here it's about changing the way
you think you said the whole book is
about that's because because we're our
biggest asset we're also my biggest
liability remember change your mind
change your life everybody wants to
change life but you have to change your
mind humans are different because we
have powerful minds and sometimes I gets
us in trouble
but if you pull it off right they can
bring you those things that you need in
life those things that you're missing
you know everybody wants the good life
like I say my TEDx talk everybody wants
the good life but not everybody gets the
good life because most people aren't
willing to do this stuff that it takes
then I willing to put in the time put in
the grind I remember when I was going to
start my business and I really wanted to
be good at it you know I was trying to
become an author and a speaker and do
these types of videos and do some online
training for people on the topics of
motivation and marketing
and you know some all these people are
saying well Brendan you you know you may
or may not be successful of that you're
you know blah and I thought it's weird
thing it's not like there's a trait of
successful people you look across
history and successful people it's not
they're not from a given background they
don't come from a specific economic
stature they're not in a position where
you know they're there at one
demographic or another Democrat it's all
over I mean we've got thousands of
collective years of history people
succeed some people do some people don't
and I think it more comes down to how do
we manage our mind and how do we manage
our days and I think that there's a
difference between successful people and
unsuccessful people in the way they
particularly think about approaching
something new
you know I think unsuccessful people
when they have a big dream and they
start thinking about what's going to be
required to accomplish that dream they
get very limiting in their beliefs about
themselves and what's possible and
specifically they say three types of
things you know the first thing they
often say is well you know I don't know
how to do that so they stop and they say
you know I I don't have those things so
they stop or they say I don't know you
know I'm not like those people I'm not
like that and so they stopped but
successful people have a different way
they have the same thing everybody
dreams you dream I dream successful
people dream people just starting out
everybody dreams everyone has the vision
everyone if they can just take five
minutes today and think about their
lives we could all come up with ways to
improve our lives and reach another
level of success joy happiness
achievement contribution fulfillment
soul you know we can all elevate but the
challenge is that them successful people
they keep stopping when they think of
what they currently know have or are but
successful people say well I want to do
that but I don't know how to do that but
instead of stopping they say well then
my job is to go learn that they take
their current limitation and they put it
on their agenda as a job to do as a
thing to figure out a thing to make
happen instead of saying well I don't
have that they say well then my job is
to go build that or I'm not like
that then they say well then my job is
to go become more of that become that
person who could accomplish those things
you know when I was starting to do
online marketing for the first time and
and I don't know if you how much of my
story you know but when I started doing
online marketing I was literally
bankrupt and I went from a place of
bankruptcy to the point where I really
committed to becoming successful at it
and in 18 months I made four point eight
million dollars four point six collected
I'm he was that's a huge leap right in
in in difference from bankrupt to
multi-millionaire in a span of 18 months
but what made that breakthrough wasn't
that I had new opportunities it wasn't
that I had new technologies it wasn't
like wow there's the internet now those
things were already there it went I went
from this level of thinking to this
level of thinking I used to say well I I
don't know how to build a web page so I
said agenda figure out how to build a
web page and I spent hours and hours and
hours at nights on weekends from my job
figuring out how to do that and I said
well I don't have one of those lists you
know I don't have any subscribers nobody
knows who I am
so I said job go build a list go get
subscribers go add value and content out
the marketplace and they'll come I mean
just keep putting stuff out there and I
also didn't say oh my gosh well I have
that dream I can't have that because I'm
not like that
because I was in a public speaker I
didn't know how to do video I wasn't
like well I'm not one of those video
people well I'm not a public speaker so
I said you know what I have to go learn
that art I have to go become a better
speaker a better communicator I have to
go become more confident I have to go
become a person capable of doing these
things I have to change myself to get
there
I can't wait for circumstances to change
so I can have my dream then our dreams
would never happen we have to get to the
point of maturity in our lives where we
say okay two things are gonna change my
life something new is gonna come into my
life and make me lucky and blessed and
maybe I can't count on that forever and
maybe now instead I have to consciously
design my life and say okay now if I
want to change if I want my dream
something new has to come from me I'm
going to become a better person I'm
going to become a person who is
optimistic who is more confident who is
more driven not because I am that now
but because we can grow that you can
become the type of person who needs to
who you need to be to achieve your ideal
life you can start today living from
your highest ideals your highest sense
of self your strongest sense of self you
don't need permission you don't need a
guy like me to look at the video camera
and say you have now permission but it's
been waiting for it you have permission
it's like at some point in your life you
just say ok I have permission to become
my best self and by becoming your best
self you start to achieve your best
things you start to contribute better
things you start to become a better
human being you can do that now today so
next time you're thinking about a big
dream don't think about the things that
well I don't know how to do that and
stop think I don't know how so set it up
on your calendar to go learn those
things I don't have that then set it up
step by step to go build that I'm not
like that then set it up step by step to
go develop those skill sets and those
competencies so you can become that and
ultimately you can achieve that dream
it's there it's waiting for you don't
stop so thank you guys so much for
watching tell us which of the clips you
liked the best leave it in the comments
below
continue to believe I will see you soon